for ginny and marcus together they're
the only people that make sense to each
other i think that's what people will
really fangirl
i mean also like you know have you seen
his cheekbones because i met your mom
last night yeah well she can be very
friendly
she asked me for weed she wasn't that
friendly you know she's always four
steps ahead of everybody i don't know
about you but
discovering your mom as a murderer would
really throw
you in for a loop i've done things i'm
not proud of but i'd do them again
i'd do anything to protect my kids like
no one ever protected me
it's me and you against the world kid
remember that
[Music]
georgia does such an incredible job of
towing the line between
charming and conniving which of her
season one secrets shocked you the most
oh my gosh
there's too many to keep track of
georgia is very hard to keep
up with she's exhausting because she has
all of these masks all of these facades
that she has to keep in line and she's
built this little house of cards for
herself
i think what she does at the very very
end with the fireworks was
the most shocking and satisfying
scene such a good line too so good
ashes of the past jenny uncovers almost
all
of georgia's secrets there's still quite
a few skeletons in that fashionable
closet
which one do you think was the most
psychologically damaging to ginny
i don't know about you but discovering
your mom as a murderer would really
throw you in for a loop i mean she knew
georgia was dangerous what with the
secret guns and the you know
hidden what is it like bored under the
closet but
to find out to put two and two together
and say oh wow my
my mom killed someone that's a little
bit and you see how she covers for her
so that
just that right there is like a red flag
georgia would be so proud though
georgia would be super proud she's
definitely the product of her mother
but yeah i think jenny just just real
coming to that realization
it just was such a shock i feel like i
don't even know who my mother is
when we last see jenny in the season one
finale she's riding off into the night
with a stolen bike and her little
brother on the back seat
do you think she has enough georgia in
her to
pull off this run away from home i think
ginny is very smart and she
knows that she has resources and
you know she is just going to figure it
out that's just what she's always done
that's what georgia has always put in
her and as much as she tries not to be
like her mom she
she really is she might not you know go
to the
same extreme lengths as georgia has but
she puts her family first she takes her
brother
and diesel has been such a wonderful
person to work with he's super talented
and she says hey we gotta get out of
here but i need to hear you say it and
they do
and yeah i think she's just a really
great big sister felix you think marcus
is going to notice his bike is gone
yeah oh for sure actually maybe not
because because he just came off that
crash so i don't even think he's looking
about it personally felix
i was super proud to see jenny in that
moment i
i love because she's beholden to
marcus's like
antics through the whole series and i
think the moment where she goes look hey
let's put this aside because i got to
deal with
i think is is really beautiful because
marcus is
is great and i love that connection but
he does come with a lot of baggage and
for virginia to stand up for herself
and actually just take charge was
beautiful to see we're just friends
right
yeah friends tony i feel like fans are
going to be shipping the hell out of
ginny and marcus
they're so irresistible y'all are about
to get
flooded with all that shipper attention
what do you think it is about this
pairing that's just so irresistible i
think
especially with marcus and the way felix
plays him
and the way the character is written
marcus subverts your your expectations
you you start off thinking oh he's you
know going to be that typical
bad boy who treats the girl poorly but
you realize he has
a past as well he has things that he
struggles with and
i think that's where ginny and marcus
really bond
for ginny and marcus together they're
the only people that make sense to each
other
they're the rock in this swirling crazy
storyline that's going on the only thing
that they have to hold on to is each
other
and i think when you see that on screen
you just immediately you want to live in
that moment for a little bit
you know every girl wants to have that
person in their life that they can
confide in and who really sees them for
who they are and that they can be
comfortable with and
ginny's finally seeing that in him and i
think that's what
what people will really fangirl i mean
also like you know have you seen his
cheekbones because
i guess you don't know anything about me
after all to quote georgia do you think
marcus is jenny's penguin i do i think
you know
there's i think i was trying to weave in
a physical thing
that kind of reflects the rest of the
relationship in that marcus can't really
sit still
or or focus on anything unless ginny's
gonna run you know so
like it's just a physical thing to
ground him but that's
exactly how he feels he can't focus
nothing makes sense
without jenny and that was really fun to
play one of my favorite things about the
show is it is such a realistic
look at what it's like being a teenager
these days
the storyline with ginny and the
self-harm with the lighter
it's just gonna hit so close to home for
so many teens out there what do you hope
that you
take away from that storyline i
really want teenagers to know that
especially if they're struggling with
something like that or if they know
someone who is struggling with something
like that
that they aren't alone and that there
are resources for them
one thing that our show runners and our
show creators did was made sure that we
consulted with mental health america
and they saw our episodes they saw it
from start to finish
and they gave us guidance on how to
properly portray this very sensitive
part of jenny's life
and you know this is for her this is a
specific thing that she does
but it is also something that is very
prevalent and i think
i just really want you know viewers to
young or old if that's something that
because this is something that no matter
your age you know
you could be going through and so i want
people to really see
themselves in that and and know that
it's okay to reach out for help
for sure i think it's really important
to communicate to young people that
you're going through something it's okay
to ask for help
it's okay to advocate for therapy but
you don't necessarily know that until
you see it so i think that's why it's so
important and why i was really really
proud and honored to be a part of
telling that story
was to have marcus eventually be
one of the only people who was honest
about his mental health honest about
having the struggle and honest about
having to get help and so
for me i was really really humbled and
really privileged to be able to be a
part of telling that and communicating
to young people that it's okay
to reach out his usual joe thank you
bri what was your reaction when you
discovered that joe
was actually the boy from the rest stop
who
changed george's life in that one moment
like
break it down for me it's one of my
favorite aspects
especially how he it is so so
heartbreaking
by the end he does such an incredible
job ray does
playing joe and it's one of the things i
love about georgia
how coy and sneaky she is and the diner
scene
in the pilot where she calls him by his
name but knows he's gonna think it's
just because he has the name tag on
you know she's always four steps ahead
of everybody does
georgia know it's joe i think so yeah
my mom deals with her problems by
ignoring them bundling them up and
packing it away
what would you like to see in season two
of ginny and georgia what are your
biggest questions you want to see
answered
i want to make sure something goes wrong
and ginny comes home most important
thing to me
but also we are really really excited
to to showcase season one and this is
this is where our heads are at right now
tony any lingering questions that you're
hoping would get answered
if we get a season two does anybody know
anything
at all about nick i mean
he's on to her that's that's what i want
to see um
but uh you know i'm just kind of like
is he on is he the new pi who knows but
um
i think season one is just super fun and
i want people to really enjoy
the beginning of this journey um like we
have
this is the new thing you're doing now
hate on mom come on
this isn't us we're like the gilmore
girls but with bigger boobs